oui
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le grand studio
du figaro on est en direct on est avec
vous c'est figaro live et on attend vos
points de vue approuvez-vous le maintien
des élections régionales au mois de juin
on vous a posé la question sur le site
du figaro on vous repose la question ce
soir cette fois ci sur twitter et on en
débat avec vous et avec jean louis
bourlanges bonsoir jean d'angély député
modem des hauts-de-seine et président de
la commission des affaires étrangères à
l'assemblée nationale avec vous avec
vous comme chaque mardi
alexis brézet bonsoir alexis directeur
d'abord vincent directeur des rédactions
du figaro
dois je le rappeler en une dans les
prochaines heures on fait le point sur
les sorties de crise on essaye on essaie
d'envisager les différents facteurs qui
vont peser permettre empêcher la sortie
de crise ducobu
croyez vous un retour d'ailleurs à la
vie normale d'ici la fin de l'été un
c'est la question qu'on vous pose sur le
site du figaro on attend vos réponses
pour l'instant vous êtes assez
pessimiste mais on va en débattre d'ici
là dans un peu moins d'une demi heure
jean castex devrait annoncer la date
proposée par le gouvernement pour les
prochaines élections régionales et
départementales alors richard ferrand a
vendu un peu la mèche matin sur rtl je
vous propose d'écouter le président de
l'assemblée nationale le premier
ministre de mon pays une première chose
va proposer que les élections aient lieu
au mois de juin
peut-être en décalant jusqu'au 27 juin
le deuxième tour ce qui était ma
deuxième proposition je m'en félicite
oui richard ferrand s'en félicite alain
qui risquent de ne pas s'en féliciter
c'est françois bayrou qui déclarait il
ya quelques jours ceci mon avis à moi
c'est que il n'est pas raisonnable de
tenir les élections dans un moment où
l'attention des citoyens et porter sur
des questions aussi graves que la santé
la maladie l'épicerie la vie la mort ces
régionales ces départements après l'été
mais c'est ce que dit le conseil
scientifique entre les lignes mais ce
n'est pas ce que devrait sur le
gouvernement
jean louis bourlanges est-ce que vous
avez des regrets moi je regarde pas
grand chose
dans cette affaire je crois que de toute
manière ces élections ont un caractère
d'irréalité
quel que soit le moment où elles auront
lieu parce que les français pour c'est
nécessaire de pourvoir au renouvellement
du consignes et conseils régionaux des
conseils départementaux mais très très
sincèrement les français s'en fiche
les français s'en fiche je la dis moi je
crois que la différence du président
bayrou je pense que il faut s'en tenir
au calendrier je trouve que j'étais même
pas partisan de retarder d'une semaine
enfin si on doit s'en tenir au
calendrier il faut faire ces élections
ça n'intéresse pas grand monde
ça va favoriser les sortants c'est pour
la majorité c'est sans doute une épreuve
a cédé assez difficile que ce soit pour
mon groupe pour mon parti le modem ou
pour la république en marche
c'est une situation très difficile ça va
favoriser de toute manière les sortants
mais c'est tout il ya des échéances
il faut qu'elles aient lieu et puis
ensuite on verra qu'est ce qu'on aurait
gagné à faire quelque chose en septembre
ou en octobre alors que les français
auront là aussi son resteront très
préoccupé par un certain nombre de
choses de toute manière cette campagne
elle sera extrêmement légère et elle
intéressera très peu de monde est triste
mais c'est comme ça en septembre en
octobre
les partisans d'un report disait alexis
que ça permettrait de faire campagne
dans des conditions un petit peu plus
optimale que une campagne mois de juin
franchement ça me préparera grand sens
parce que si c'est pour les faire en
septembre dire qu'on refait une campagne
normale au mois d'août
ça me paraît pas tellement plus
convaincant que de dire qu'on va faire
une campagne anormal au mois de juin
enfin bon ce sera en octobre
si on devait faire une campagne il
faudrait la faire en septembre mais moi
j'ai eu d'accord avec eux je crois
franchement que cette affaire mais avec
un non-problème un peu surréaliste dans
tous les pays du monde
des élections on a fait les élections
donald trump le méchant donald trump
fait des élections qu'est ce qu'on
aurait dit s'il n'avait pas fait les
élections au motif qu'il y avait une
crise sanitaire aux états unis qui était
un tout petit peu plus sérieuse à
l'époque qu'aujourd'hui en france oui
cela dit on avait on a quand même le
vote par correspondance qui a été compté
il ya alors tandis qu'en france où il
avait proposé au modem
le vote par correspondance et ça a été
serré c'est là où françois bayrou
un point de vue assez assez logique il a
dit - voulait le vote par correspondance
est vrai leur faisais c'est vrai qu'on
peut s'interroger sur pourquoi pendant
un an on n'a rien fait sur ce sujet là
sur le vote par correspondance sur les
votes informatique parce que c'est aussi
une technique alors c'est compliqué il
faut tout il faut vérifier qu'ils aient
pas de triche
mais c'est des choses qui peuvent se
faire aider pays où ça se fait c'est
vrai que pendant un an n'a rien fait sur
ces sujets là c'est aussi pendant un an
n'a rien fait pour faire des lits
d'hôpitaux supplémentaire n'a rien à
faire mais vraiment l'air de vote dont
10 en grand jeu c'est vrai qu' on aurait
pu peut-être plus de travailler ensemble
de sujets mais pour autant je veux dire
on a déjà mis quand même me semble-t-il
pas mal la démocratie entre parenthèses
depuis le début de cette crise notamment
le parlement en disant qu' en période de
crise c'est l'exécutif qui est en
première ligne et que le parlement où on
lui demande plus ou moins son avis
plutôt moins que plus et qu'on va faire
et des lois d'exception etc etc on va
pas maintenant supprimer les élections
seraient les seuls en europe à les
supprimer
ce n'est franchement pas de sens je
comprends pas pourquoi le gouvernement
s'est engagé dans cette voie pour en
plus finir par y renoncer après d'une
sorte de deux allers retours de
palinodies assez intéressant pour moi je
ne savais pas qu'il y renoncerait et
j'avais de meilleures décidé alors que
mon groupe est épais pour le report
j'avais décidé de m'opposer et au
gouvernement et à mon groupe sur ce plan
sa maman distinguer pas de mots posés et
là je vois que je vais voter avec le
gouvernement contre mon groupe sas et
j'ai attendu ma franchement je comprend
pas très bien pourquoi
françois bayrou et patrick mignola
pourquoi les centristes ce qu'ils sont à
peu près lettre qu'ils étaient les seuls
à être officiellement vraiment protégés
qui sont bien contents c'est pas de la
façon dont ils sont très bas mais
semaine pour priver les portais des
élections je suis d'accord il sera levé
que je sais c'est mon argumentation je
dis c'est pas parce qu'on est on n'est
pas content de la façon dont a été
traité manipuler sur les en plus on
avait demandé une consultation qui
d'ailleurs était discutable parce que
c'est pas forcément au maire de se
prononcer sur la ferme on avait demandé
nous le modèle on avait demandé au maire
est donc là le verdict des mères est
assez clair donc jeu
très franchement je ne crois pas que ce
soit un problème très très important
mais je pense que les arguments de
simple bon sens nous conduisent à
vouloir voter avant la levée des mères
est assez clair le recours à la
consultation des maires avaient été
décriées par les opposants europort oui
kim attention c'est le monde fait de la
tactique là dedans sauf moi euh oui
aucun cas de faire de la tactique
sergent louis après c'est vrai que cette
histoire de consultation c'est comme
lancer dans une condition
d'improvisation assez baroque c'est que
ce truc pour trois jours on décide de
demander l'avis des gens en espérant
qu'ils vont répondre non la tuilerie
produit alors ce qui était content sont
pour vous voulez ce qu'on souhaitait que
j'ai répondu je ne sais pas c'est quand
même qui avait d'après ce qu'on nous dit
d'après ce qu'on entend dans près ce
qu'on lit y compris dans le film we que
subissent ample et guéret du côté des
formes de responsables politiques
ses rangs dont on vient de parler
qu'aujourd'hui nous dit que ils ont ça
très bien de le décaler d'une semaine
c'est pas vrai du tout il voulait qu'on
le renvoie en septembre en octobre et de
la part du président la république quand
même la vague tentation de se dire plus
ça traîne plus c'est dans longtemps plus
à d'abord ça écarte de nos lèvres la
coupe amère de de la défaite électorale
m'enfin ça change pas grand chose
oui ça la rapproche des échéances
présidentielles et législatives de mai
mais peut-être qu'il y avait le look le
rêve dans l'esprit de certains de se
dire que plus on retarde cette affaire
la plus on empoisonne la droite ce qui
est vrai c'est vrai que la droite avec
ses trois candidats présents candidat
putatif à l'élection présidentielle qui
sont tous les toutous les trois
candidats à l'élection aux élections
régionales c'est à dire
les classements ça les empoisonnait con
cocon qu'on n'obtienne pas ces élections
et ils ont besoin des élections pour
commencer à faire le tri la droite a
besoin qui est des élections pour
commencer à faire le tri parmi tous ces
candidats
est ce que c'était est-ce que c'était ça
le calcul je ne suis pas moi je n'ai pas
tout à fait impossible pour ce soit dit
allez on va on va regarder la droite
mais là vous lisez votre journal alors
vous vous auto informer si je vous
admire leur accès à tous les complets
dans le figaro daté d'aujourd'hui sur le
report il faut ça mais quand on ne
trouve pas de raison rationnelle à une
chose si quand on ne trouve pas de
raison vraisemblable à une chose on est
forcé de se dire qu'il ya deux raisons
au noble et est pas clair vous avez vous
aimez votre esprit votre esprit
satanique se donne libre cours aux
enchères alexis mais en réalité il y
avait quand même une raison et qui est
tout à fait envisageable c'est de dire
qu'en septembre on aurait quand même on
aurait tourné le dos on espère à la
pandémie et à toutes ces restrictions
sur la campagne électorale
c'est quand même un argument assez fort
pour se veut moi je trouve que c'est pas
très convaincant pour les raisons que
vous disiez tout à l'heure
de toute manière on n'allait pas faire
campagne au mois d'août on a évoqué en
septembre et que de toute manière il n'y
avait pas de sens quand même les
politiciens qui ne sont pas les moins
aguerris ferrand bayrou ces journées qui
tousse susurrer à l'oreille tu que vous
regardez encore un joli nom mais parce
que je suis moi je suis moi je suis
aguerrie je suis aguerrie
après débat politique c'est exactement
ça aimé et que les
un symptôme de responsables susurrer à
l'oreille du président de public que
c'était sans doute pas un mauvais calcul
le bayrou s'était c'est une question de
plus tôt de principe pour qu'ils aient
une campagne et compte tenu du fait
qu'ils n'avaient pas le il n'y avait pas
le vote pas quand ronan ce qu'il avait
demandé est ce qu'il y avait et là il ya
un agacement très net parce que mon
groupe a accepté de façon à mon avis
bien considérer le président de mon
groupe que j'aime bien par ailleurs mais
il a accepté de façon inconsidérée de le
diktat de la république en marche sur
l'abandon la proportionnelle sans aucune
raison sans aucune raison on pouvait si
vous voulez pas ce serait pas voté mais
on n'avait aucune raison en plus de
consentir à notre propre à notre propre
défaite il fallait dire non maintenez ça
et donc il ya une assez grande
frustration au sein du groupe modem sur
la façon dont on procède il faut dire
que ce en plus cette déclaration on va
voter pour une décision qui est prise
paille à tous année mais alors que le
modem a quand même des chances aux
régionales de s'en tirer relativement
mieux qu'en marche qui n'a aucun espoir
oui on marche ne peut pas avoir sauf
miracle de le point de vue dans marche
je me garderai bien de faire des
pronostics mais dans la région c'est par
exemple nous avons un excellent candidat
dans la région c'est exactement à témoin
possible à fait excellent candidat
non mais aussi dans le sud dans le sud
ouest oui oui elle a eu à madame la
ministre thériault isaac non cherchez
bien
c'est très bien ça veut dire que
j'espère la majorité à des victoires au
soir des régionales ce que je lui
souhaite c'est vous qui elle devra ses
victoires au modem mais pour là il
faudrait que je me marre qu'on rende
hommage public la valeureuse troupes
centristes
shaval couleuvres sur coup la couleur
sur couleuvres pas toujours mais il
reste que notre groupe attire alors que
le groupe dans marche est plutôt l'objet
de fuites donc nous nous sommes le filet
de sécurité de la majorité vous avez pas
jusqu'à revendiquer la victoire
éventuelle d'hervé morin s'ils
l'emportent en normandie
non je pense que nous sommes nous ne
sommes pas tout à fait sur cette ligne
hervé morin a quand même on ne peut pas
dire qu'ils sont manifestés depuis
depuis le 2
2010cette par un soutien acharné à la
politique du président de la république
on ne peut pas dire ça il ya des
centristes
du côté du président et des centristes
or l'opposition c'est le charme du
centre d'avoir toujours un pied dans les
deux corps ça permet de la fin de se
retrouver du bon côté coûte et je trouve
je vous trouve bien bien impertinent
avec le centre si on avait monopole de
chasse aux rêveries l'impression que du
côté de a l'air fou d'heure c'est vrai
mais est il du côté socialiste aussi
sera pas mal de socialistes qui sont
jamais ceux qui sont au nord les écolos
on a des écolos chez nous il ya des
écolos dehors peut-être cher alexis de
voeux devons-nous constaté l'ats la
recomposition de ville est voulu parler
peut-être à un fossé infranchissable
entre hervé morin devrait dorénavant et
le reste des rails à l copains fauchés
entre hervé morin et edouard philippe
apparemment apparemment je doute qu'ils
emmanuel macron ait eu réellement le
choix de maintenir ces élections étant
donné la pression exercée par
l'opposition nous dit nous dit rudy si
l'on en juge que la population n'est pas
en danger lorsqu'elle s'entassent dans
les transports en commun elle peut bien
se déplacer pour aller voter nous dit
cet autre internaute
cet autre internaute pardon sur internet
jean-françois nous dit enfin un peu de
cohérence avec les annonces faites
kriss kross estime que décalé d'une
semaine des élections est d'un ridicule
ultime ça c'est un petit côté en même
temps on d'échelle pas pourquoi ils ont
décalé une semaine je pense que ça va
gagner où il gagnerait quelques jours de
plus alors là les mauvaises livre les
mauvais esprits c'est que le départ en
vacances
c'est à dire de toute façon comme ça on
se prend une raclée de 27 juin tout le
monde est en vacances
oui j'allais même chose si on inclut ce
qui est pas du tout évident en boutique
mais on peut dire les normales les ars
ne seront pas très favorable à la
majorité dans cette élection qu'on se
prenne la une raclée le 20 ou le 27 très
franchement la différence de grégorini
dans le vrai argument pour maintenir ces
cons seraient les seuls en europe à
différer une élection et il n'y a aucune
raison et la saison qu'on n'est pas plus
mauvais klereo
voilà est le vrai empêche pas me
semble-t-il pour macron de repousser
c'était l'impossibilité dé laure de dire
on va ouvrir les restaurants à la
minière à la terrasse à la mi-mai à la
fin mais ceux-ci la mi juin cela et on
ouvre on ouvre on nous parce que son
désir et ô combien légitime et son
projet nécessaire politiquement c'est de
montrer aux français qu on en sort et
qu'on ouvre c'est pas possible de dire
on en sort on ouvre et de dire on ferme
en même temps il ya un moment français
sont favorables à l'ouverture des cafés
et la fermeture des voies mais enfin
quand même compliqué d renouveau le café
et enfin moi je referme les bureaux et
une attitude de bon sens il ya une
consultation le bizarre mais très claire
dans ses résultats
l'émissaire a vraiment logique sauf que
c'est une tempête dans un verre nous et
je trouve très sincèrement qu'on en
parle un peu trop longtemps parce que
c'est pas prodigieusement intéressant il
ya excusez-nous l'actualité partenaires
de décevantes mais mais pas ceux qu'il a
quand même
nicole nous disait bien sûr qu'il faut
les maintenir à c'est peut-être un autre
argument sait maintenant comment se
protéger masque gel stylos etc
un stylo stylo personnel pour signer
pour six mais pas pour rayer ou pour
pour le dépouillement le deuxième tour
des municipales n'a pas été un problème
nous dit elle un petit peu différent du
premier tour on vous posez donc la
question sur sur twitter emmanuel macron
at il raison de maintenir des élections
régionales
en juin on va voir les résultats je note
en tous les cas gens à ça c'est
déconnecté alors la réponse est oui mais
la réponse est oui et majoritairement
filles allaient reconnais j'ai d'abord
et c'est le miracle justement de la
reconnexion ça gaze chekwa 75 % de oui
pour
soutenu par une large majorité et donc
on soutient votre minorité au sein du
groupe russe en coulisses on retient que
vous êtes aguerri mais pas politicien
mais hérité du mouvement démocrate et on
peut dire héritier de la démocratie créé
la seule ligne de la majorité
surtout quand vous accusez avec cette
année c'est ce que j'ai accompli mais
moi ça m'a blessé vous savez que
maintenant avéré c'est cette blessure
doivent être n'at elle pas survivre à
sur les gradins aux français qui heurte
la conviction de celui à qui on
l'adresse est une idée il les fit in en
une idée encore c'est pas bien gardées
il faut pas blesser une sensibilité il
faut pas foncer une sensibilité
oui c'est encore beaucoup plus grave ce
qui est compliqué ça limite quand même
le débat alors il nous reste un petit
quart d'heure
j'aurais adoré qu'on ait ce débat à
partir du autour du livre de caroline
fourest sur la tyrannie des eaux les
offenser ou celui de mathieu bock-côté
ou celui de matthieu bock courbe il a
d'ailleurs si on racialiste on en a on
l'a montrée justement vendredi dernier
avec la une du figaro magazine
également en parlant du livre où
subsisteraient d'un arbre okpala ya
beaucoup de livres en ce moment sur
cette tyrannie des minorités aux france
c'est alors on va revenir sur une
question que vous avez abordé justement
enfin deux premiers débats sur justement
quand peut-on espérer un retour à la
normale la question qu'on vous pose sur
le site du figaro et vous êtes assez
pessimiste pour l'instant c'est croyez
vous un retour normal à la normale d'ici
l'été et vous répondez non pour
l'instant à 68% un petit peu plus
d'ailleurs parce que les chiffres que
vous voyez c'était juste avant le début
de l'émission
on se pose la question puisqu'on a vu
l'ouverture des terrasses de pub en
grande bretagne après quatre mois de
fermeture on se pose également la
question avec l'émergence d'une nouvelle
menace la menace d'un nouveau variant le
variant brésilien voici à cet égard la
mesure annoncée par le chef du
gouvernement tout à l'heure à
l'assemblée nationale
nous constatons mais oui nous dit pas
danser la vérité nous constatons que la
situation s'aggrave et nous avons donc
décidé de suspendre jusqu'à nouvel ordre
tous les vols entre le brésil et la
france
jean louis bourlanges le président de la
commission des fêtes et rageur que vous
êtes approuvent cette décision
écoutez moi j'étais j'ai été très choqué
j'écoutais ce matin les informations de
la timidité des mesures qui étaient
envisagés à l'aéroport de paris ou
ailleurs je pense que c'est typiquement
on est en présence d'un d'un fléau très
très très très caractérisée qui vient du
brésil d un pays comme le portugal par
exemple qui a des liens et normes
historiques et paix permanent avec le
brésil a interrompu je pense qu'il faut
prendre des mesures drastiques et des
mesures intercontinental elles sont
faciles à prendre surveiller une
frontière intercontinental c'est autre
chose que de surveiller la frontière
franco allemande
donc je pense qu'il fallait
effectivement le faire ça je soutiens
totalement le le gouvernement dans cette
affaire il faut c'est typiquement des
mesures ponctuelles qui doivent être
très fermement conduite on verra pour
combien de temps on va voir si les
vaccins fonctionne mais là ce qui
apparaît sur ce ce virus brésilien sait
qu'il est extraordinairement contagieux
et donc il faut vraiment agir agir vite
et agir fermement donc là ça je trouve
dans la fermeté s'impose
l'argument qui était donné par notamment
le ministre des transports jean baptiste
jebbari c'est à dire qu'on peut pas
interdire aux ressortissants français ou
aux personnes qui vivent en france qui
arrive du brésil à la préfecture la
preuve qu'on peut c'est qu'on va
supprimer les vols donc c'est pas on dit
qu'on peut pas jouer qu'au moment où on
peut tous les pays font des détails mais
on peut suspendre des vols on peut se
dire la compagnie ben non c'est fini
puis vous débrouiller et vous mais enfin
quand quand on appuie souvent on peut
faire un certain nombre de choses et moi
je suis fasciné de voir que sur ces
questions de frontières de surveillance
des frontières de fermeture défendre les
espèces de points aveugles 2.2 paralyse
au fond très politique très idéologique
depuis le début de cette crise ou des
rappelez-vous le tout tout tout tout
début on disait déjà il faut fermer les
frontières on nous avait dit que nous ne
faut surtout pas fermer les frontières
leval le virus ne connaît pas les
frontières oui mais revient sur les
conséquences bien que les virus s'arrête
pas aux frontières mais les gens
s'arrêtent aux frontières et il a fallu
des mois et des mois pour commencer il
faut nuancer parce que s'ils virus
apparaît dans deux pays s'est
effectivement ça en revanche il faut
enlever ses frontières intra régional
mais j'en voyais très gravement et vous
le début oui oui le début restent donc
deux voix se sont élevées pour dire il
faut fermer les frontières nationales
on a refusé je pense par une sorte d' a
priori c'est pas bien de fermer les
frontières là faut pas se fermer sur soi
l'ouverture des frontières est un bien
en soi et huit mois après sept mois
après on a fini par le faire n'ont été
d'aucun répit avec un bien en soi c'est
pas ça c'était et c'est extrêmement
difficile amerturme des activités est ce
qu'on l'a fait il a fait mais on a fini
par le faire
mais lorsque qu en jambes et en est on
on en a laissé le bénéfice de cette
exigence
malheureusement à marine le pen et après
on a dit parce que marine le pen réclame
on ne le fera pas et puis si cette moins
huit mois après on a fini par le faire
et là sur la sphère du brésil c'est un
peu la même chose sur une grille
heureusement plus brèves qui s'est joué
mais c'est ça fait 8 10 jours qu'on
annule qu'est ce qu'on fait on laisse
venir les gens du brésil pendant huit
dix jours nous dit c'est pas possible
c'est pas bien puis le 8/10 du jour ont
fini par lila fois les dents mieux les
villans mieux on le fait mais il ya
quand même quelque chose qui est de
l'ordre du de l'inquiétude vous aide un
sacré des genres pas on peut plus
facilement les accords je suis d'accord
avec vous sur le fait qu'il faut pas
être timide et qu'on a été et que comme
toujours en france on est timide
on en a 10 opposition les ménages etc
ça c'est une erreur mais je ne suis pas
d'accord avec vous sur le caractère
idéologique que ce refus en réalité nous
savons bien de fermer une frontière
ça provoque d'état notamment la
frontière regarder le wii balance
effectivement quand on allait chez moi
j'avais été très choqué au début quand
on avait desserré les gens de la douve
var à lyon elle fait vivre et à l'époque
on nous disait qu'il fallait pas fermer
qu'on ne pouvait pas fermer et puis on a
pu on peut pas au début puis au bout
d'un moment le jour ce jour il ya un
coussin volant un coût humain un cru
social mais les gens qui peuvent plus
travailler il ya année ce ne sont pas
des mesures qu'on prend à la légère déjà
l'algérie avait peu de temps pour moment
que coûte cher parce qu' il vaut mieux
bloquer tout de suite l'arrivée de dix
personnes qui attendent qu'un et 5000
qui sont rentrés montée d'arrivée de
fermer la porte derrière elle la demande
et chisso le brésil a fâché mais j'ai
pas vu la mesure que fire j'ai vu la non
ce monsieur cache sexe mais au-delà de
ça moi je crois que la vraie mesure
c'est la quarantaine parce que c'est mon
blog des les gens peuvent venir les gens
qui viennent du brésil devraient être
mises en quarantaine de quarantaine
peut-être pas quarante jours j'avais
alors au 18 l'a encore laure moysset
cessera font les jouines taiwan sont
légion mais en veillant sur un site de
la quarantaine c'est bien sûr vous
demande où mme allemand et tout moment
vous demander un engagement de respecter
vous même chez vous la 41e est nommé
chef de l'état et l'ush ya sûrement fin
il ya peut-être six personnes sur dix
qui le font bien
ou 5 sur 10 2 sur 10 qui le font à
moitié et les trois autres quidams en
fichez je le fais pas eh ben on va donc
parce qu'on n'ose pas parce que toute
mesure un peu coercitives toute mesure
un peu fermes qui rompent avec les
habitudes et inquiétante suspecte
logiquement nous sommes notés il avait
remarqué qu'une sommes dans un pays qui
est que comme disait le regretté alain
le filet
c'est un peuple de citoyens contre les
pouvoirs donc quand c'est quand même il
ya une capacité de résistance
nous pouv oir une croix est forte et le
messie le pouvoir attention si on est
d'accord ça dépend sur quoi si on avait
dit aux gens ferment des frontières vous
aviez 90% d'adhésions
si on avait dit dès qu'on prend des
mesures notamment pour ce faire mais
vis-à-vis de l'étranger on a 80 %
d'adhésion donc si on ne le fait pas
c'est pour d'autres raisons mais c'est
pas parce qu'on craint les réactions de
l'opinion
il ya sur plein de sujets si on
demandait sélectionnant par payer de
gérer l'argent de de la moselle la
meurthe-et-moselle de la moselle surtout
de d'alsace c'est une c'est extrêmement
difficile pour eux de de fermer les
frontières donc vous avez les réactions
non mais je ne dis pas je crois que nous
sommes
d'une façon générale depuis des
décennies la france est un pays qui a du
mal à prendre des décisions publiques
coureuses jeu cros et c'est ce qui en
fait je on s'assure ce diagnostic là on
est d'accord ce qui nous distingue c'est
que je crois que derrière cette
difficulté à passer à l'acte il y a
quand même une idéologie pas constitué
pas politique mais un sentiment général
que non c'est pas bien non il faut pas
non martin a quand même le paf de fermer
voyez il a été à mulhouse c'était la
frontière oui mais on n'a pas pu le
faire mais chez nous non mais quand
c'est parti en chine n'a pas voulu
fermer les vols venant de chine
rappelez-vous parce qu'on nous a dit on
ferme pas les frontières
il faut quand même se souvenir de ça
depuis on a fait du chemin heureusement
mais c'est vrai que le premier réflexe à
dire non peut pas non c'est pas bien
donc quand même tous nos principes font
qu'on peut pas ben oui à la qualité pour
pas compliquer la vie des gens je les
coups bas mais juste par rapport à ça
deux peut-être de questions jean lui la
première c'est que vous dites les
français n'adhèrent pas à des mesures
fortes
pourtant ça lui que vous n'avez pas eu
le sentiment que au moment du premier
confinement par rapport à une décision
qui a été forte qui a était inédite une
première dans l'histoire d'un pays de
chichi ça a été ça a été pour ça je
crois qu'on a quand même pris les
mesures des mesures fortes à ce moment
là les légendes ont été paniqués à juste
titre et ils ont accepté traite et ça a
été assez efficace
ça a été assez efficace premier
confinement certainement qu'il réponde à
faire de façon à tout type comment
c'était un peu un démenti aux propos
d'alain à ce moment là l'idée que oui
mais non mais non dénommée fralin c'est
compliqué parce qu'alain lui même a été
un combattant de la première guerre
mondiale extrêmement qu ailleurs la
seconde guerre c'est plus incertain
son rôle mais la première guerre
mondiale il a été un combattant
extrêmement courageux il ya été anodin
il a refusé mais etc les français ont
fait en quarts entre 14 et 18
ils ont fait des sacrifices énormes les
français ont une capacité de sacrifices
mais ils ont une capacité aussi de
résistance et c'est là où c'est
compliqué et le confinement ça a été un
sacrifice qu'ils ont accéléré parce
qu'ils ont vu dit fallait faire dans
l'ensemble dans leur immense majorité
d'une discipline parfois même d'une
docilité incroyable et jusqu'à
aujourd'hui
ou alors on monte en épingle trois
déjeuners par 6-3 dîner par là et les
jeunes qui en ont par-dessus la tête qui
ne respectent plus rien ça c'est vrai et
on peut les comprendre mais dans
l'ensemble corps social est quand même
une très très très très très grande
docilité et sur ces sujets notamment
khaled relatif à la protection des
frontières la protection vis-à-vis de
l'immigration la protection sur ces
sujets là il ya une unanimité dans le
désir de protection
je voudrais faire référence ou
l'excellent papier de jacques julliard
que la fia quelques jours dans fear au
parlant de la démocratie contre les
citoyens et huit sections demander
l'avis des citoyens sur tarn de sujets
notamment tous ces sujets là relatif
d'identité aux frontières les citoyens
au rex où il y aurait d'abord distant
s80 et à ancerville réjouissant d'amr
pas le problème numéro un vis-à-vis du
brésil c'est le problème vis-à-vis la
chine au début mais le problème numéro 1
c'était c'est l'organisation de la
société bien sûr vous à l'agencé on
aurait effectivement la résidence aux
frontières là on tombe sur des sondés
et des idéaux types très fort sur la
souveraineté etc et donc ça il y a une
résonance pc c'est autre chose les vrais
problèmes
mais les vrais problèmes moi je suis
d'accord avec ce que ce qu'on lit dans
le figaro est ce qu'on dit dans dans le
dans d'autres dans d'autres journaux
je crois que le vrai problème qui a été
révélé par cette cette pandémie
c'est l'extraordinaire inadaptation de
l'état son attaquant bureaucratique pas
d'état technocratique contrairement à ce
qu'on dit quand on est d'accord on met
en cause l'ena l'état bureaucratique et
laon létard était un formidable
assureurs social est détestable
prestataires de services on se pose
également la question d'un calendrier de
la sortie de crise on évoque début mai
pour le retour à l'école mi mai pour la
réouverture des terrasses une levée des
restrictions au début de l'été vous n'y
croyez pas un peu trop pour l'instant en
tous les cas c'est ce que vous lui dites
par rapport à la question qui vous est
posée sur le site du figaro et c'est peu
dire qu'en la matière le gouvernement
est un peu dans le brouillard comme
l'indiquent cette réponse que nous a
faite hier le ministre de l'agriculture
julien de normandie sur le plateau
d'auditions publiques l'émission co
produite par la chaîne parlementaire et
le figaro après la question de la
réouverture on le souhaite tous mais
tous infiniment je veux dire ce sera une
libération
le jour où on pourra retourner en
terrasse et ça ça dépend d'une seule
chose aujourd'hui c'est la vaccination
mais moi je me fie au calendrier défini
par le par le président de la république
ce dont je suis sûr c'est que pour tenir
ce calendrier c'est toute la montée en
puissance de de la vaccination et que
les énergies de toutes et tous
tout responsable politique quel qu'il
soit aujourd'hui c'est d'avoir les yeux
rivés sur la courbe de la vaccination
plus que des élections si je puis dire
leur part d'audience sur les élections
mais trois corps de vaccination pour
l'instant mais évidemment qui sait pas
mais on peut parler enfin peut pas à la
fois leur reprocher quand ils donnent
des dates de dire vous dites n'importe
quoi vous donner des dates que vous
tenez pas et puis quand il donne pas de
date des rats vous savez pas ben non il
n'en sait rien personne ne sait
exactement les choses
euh là où je serais plus optimiste que
nous les internautes et nos lecteurs et
que et que lui sait que si on regarde
quand même si on fait deux colonnes
parce qu'on sait pas quand les choses
vont ensemble on voit les facs on voit
les lignes de force sur fait deux
colonnes on met deux
ce qui est positif autre côté ce qui est
négatif dans le positif il ya
effectivement la vaccination
bon on a pris beaucoup de retard on
s'est débrouillé vraiment peu on note
tout fait de travers mais enfin
maintenant quand même ça va quand même
arrivé alors ça va peut-être moins vite
peut-être qu'astrazeneca fait l'objet
d'un rejet peut-être que johnson &
johnson a assez de problème
mais malgré tout la vaccination ça ne
fait qu'augmenter c'est un premier
facteur il y à un deuxième facteur
malgré tout c'est le confinement
je crois pas que le confinement sur l'
arme absolue mais n'empêche que le fait
ou moins on sort moins on se contacte
moi on se contacte moi ça sera bon donc
la courbe le mans il ya un troisième
facteur dont on ne parle jamais mais qui
malgré tout n'avait fait sortir de la
sphère l'année dernière à la même époque
c'est la météo pourquoi ça s'est arrêté
l'année dernière c'est l'effet effet
confinés par dons cumulés du confinement
il est dur et chaud et du printemps il
faut attendre octobre achats milite pour
les élections maintenant
mais exactement le risque à mon avis est
des bons donc on a trois facteurs
positifs qui sont les vaccins le les
effets du confinement et les effets de
la météo il va finir quand même par
faire beau et il ya dans la colonne d'en
face un effet négatif qui sont ces
nouveaux variants dont on ne sait pas
trop quoi penser mais dont on croit
comprendre quand même qu'ils sont pas
très très bon même si par exemple le
voyais en anglais dont on nous avait dit
qu'il était à la fois plus contagieux et
plus dangereux n'est que plus contagieux
ce qui déjà est embêtant mais donc bon
donc on donc mais si on fait le si on
fait l'analyse en partie double on se
dit finalement il ya quand même pas mal
de facteurs qui peuvent faire espérer
que d'ici cet été ça s'arrange
et à part ça qu'est ce qu'on peut dire
de plus moi j'en sais rien moi je me
bats je ne ne peux pas jouer à madame
soleil si oui je ne peux pas regarder
dans la boule de cristal je crois que
c'était c'est un peu l'erreur je suis
d'accord avec ce que dit julien
normandie il faut est essentiellement
suivre les courbes ce qu'il faudrait la
communication n'est pas assez
synthétique c'est à dire que je trouve
que les français devraient bénéficier
régulièrement j'ai toujours préconisé ça
sans avoir été entendu
tous les mois il devrait y avoir un
point technique pas seulement médical
mais un point général sur tous les
fronts et elles font économique le front
social le front psychologique la
détérioration de l est évidemment le
front pandémique de voir quels sont les
éléments nouveaux quelles sont les
informations dont on dispose sur la
contagion sur la létalité quelles sont
les hypothèses qu'on antilles
et quels sont les préconisations qui
s'en dégage et je pense que si on avait
ce rendez vous réguliers les français au
lieu de recevoir des informations un peu
comme un bombardement recevra une
feuille danalyse une feuille de route
qui leur permettraient non pas de
prévoir mais de comprendre ce qui ce qui
dépendra ce qui déterminera leur avenir
et de se comporter en fonction de cela
là moi je suis d'accord avec les
analyses avec si je pense qu'il ya des
éléments positifs
je pense d'une façon générale que à
travers tout ce tumulte ce qui restera
dans cinq ans quand on réfléchir à ce
qui s'est passé ce qui restera ça sera
la formidable rapidité non pas des
administrations tout était un peu
pataude
mais la formidable rapidité de réaction
de l'ensemble je pense que cette maladie
qu'on ne connaissait pas il ya quinze
mois qu'on a découvert comme ça on va
avoir
on a on a trouvé une multitude de
vaccins on est en train de les produire
en massivement on doit vacciner 8
milliards d'êtres humains enfin c'est
quand même pas rien on les produit on va
inventer un traitement on va avoir dans
quelques mois un traitement
c'est il ya une premier alors le le moi
je vais faire
il ya quand même la réaction des
sociétés d'innovation capitaliste c'est
assez prodigieuse ce qui restera c'est
cette rapidité alors là dedans il ya des
petits malins comme israël ou comme
d'autres qui tire plus vite que leur
ombre et qui donc se sont en avance mais
de toute manière ce qui est globalement
le problème c'est qu'il ya encore un
déficit massif de nombre de doses par
rapport aux besoins qui seront avant
tout qu'ils sont un peu en retard etc
mais ça avance ça va se rattraper et
sauf accident
c'est à dire l'apparition d'un variante
la vaillant qui résisterait à tous et
qui impliquerait d'autres vaccins on va
quand même en sortir alors là où on va
là où je suis inquiet son il faut quand
même réfléchir c'est on va s'en sortir
dans quelles conditions économiquement
on va s'en servir dans quelles
conditions ce que commercial allemand
commercialement on va s'en sortir dans
quelles conditions
géopolitiquement il ya quand même et a
quasiment
alors oui c'est ça dans quel ordre les
différents oui pays du monde il faut
bien son job du monde vont en sortir
c'est pas la même chose en sortie on
s'en sortira mais c'est manière dont
sera libéré que d'en sortir les premiers
et on voit que les écarts se creusent
c'est comme une course une épreuve les
plus forts creuse l'écart et là
malheureusement même si globalement la
réponse collective et rapide
malheureusement il y en a qui
soutiennent des réponses quand même un
peu quand on voit que les chinois avoue
que lors que leur vaccin ne marche pas
c'est qu'ils doivent vraiment pas marché
du tout et les 25 on nous oppose ces
réactions chinois les vaccins le vaccin
n'existe il existe ce qu'ils endurent
alimenter l'économie asiatique et
chinoise était repartie
oui bon la caso lui manque que
l'économie américaine est en train de
repartir très vite et que dans les
landes on va voir et qu'à la terre de
l'eau pour voir ce qu'on va voir ce que
la france mais c'est important
bien sûr qu'on en sortira est-ce qu'on
va s'en sortir
je pense qu'il faut on va s'en sortir
pandémique mans je pense assez
rapidement dans quelques mois mais
économiquement socialement culturel
d'ascenseur le tonus de la société et va
être quelque chose d'absolument tout cet
argent qui aidera injectés dans la
machine pour gagner l'équivalent de 85
des américains ne vont pas jeter en
parle d'ailleurs de la mal non mais les
américains qui ont fait ça parce que lui
cette quantité de l'équipe est adossé à
une puissance la question c'est est-ce
que les liquidités qu'elle injecte
l'europe dans sa machine où ces machines
sont adossées à une puissance en
quittant même encore une puis change
dynamisme suffisant non est ce qu'il ya
une puissance forte oui est-ce que de
puissance politique
nos gars ce qui fait la force de ce qui
a permis aux états unis de faire du
déficit depuis la guerre c'est sa
puissance politique
vous êtes donc un petit peu plus
optimiste que nous intervenons je vous
le confirme je vous donne quelques
messages c'est intéressant en tout cas
d'avoir ce ressenti samir nous dit à la
question croyez vous un retour à la vie
normale
cet été non car il y aura le variant
brésilien puis un autre variant puis un
nouveau confinement qui nous emmènera
bien jusqu'en 2022
navarro qui n'a rien à voir avec le
commissaire mais qui est impérial et
j'ai calé un indien croyez-moi empêché
non je ne crois je n'y crois plus même
si c'était le cas mes études sont bien
gâcher nous dit c'était déjà le suivant
les gars là dessus c'est fort et très
fort ils vont nous dit si les choses se
passent bien peut-être trois quatre
semaines normale vers la fin juillet
mais je ne pense pas que nous aurons un
retour totalement à la normale il faut
être sacrément croquant celui pour le
croire je pense être croit plutôt à la
statistique c'est à dire lorsqu'il s'est
passé l'an dernier et puis à
brillantissime alors dernière d'être
comme tranquille juin juillet août
ah non mais on aurait dû réagir plus tôt
puisque dès la fin août
c'étaient les jeunes c'est elle et les
vingtenaires côté mais dès la fin août
on a vu des chars étaient toutes les
analyses sont formelles ça a été les
concentrations de jeunes qui ont été
alors j'en veux pas aux jeunes ils ont
de plus de vitalité
on l'est on leur a caché leurs études
donc c'est pas s'agit pas de moraliser
dans cette affaire mais de constater
qu'effectivement on avait dès le début
septembre
ddd signé je crois que le gouvernement
aurait dû confier très vite
en tous les cas pas question qu'on vous
pose c'est croyez vous un retour à la
normale d'ici l'été et vous répondez
toujours en fin d'émission un nom à 10
d'ici la fin de l'été ou le début de
l'ère plutôt dc dc le d'ici l'été on
avait dit oui moment donc c'est à plus
de 68 % que vous dites 'non merci
beaucoup de nous avoir suivi on se
retrouve demain même heure même endroit
pour deux autres débats à très vite sur
figurent beck
[Musique]